more than two and a half years after
Gentry of this
of this the most prominent instigator of
the capital Riot from that day has
finally been arrested and charged with a
crime
years after other January sixth thirds
were convicted and served prison
sentences
friendly lectern enthusiasts Midwestern
grannies the whole gamut of January 6th
there's years after that the giant dude
who spent two days encouraging everyone
to storm the capital was finally
arrested and charged with uh
disorderly conduct
hmm
no seditious conspiracy charges
no terrorist enhancement charge
not even so much as a trespassing on
restricted grounds misdemeanor
and no explanation as to why Ray Epps
conspicuously uniquely perhaps was not
charged as U.S Marshals were sent to
round up just about everyone in the
proximity of the capital that day
wonder why that is let's review the tape
as soon as president Trump is finished
speaking we are going to the
Gap drop is done speaking we are going
through the capitol that's where our
problems
okay folks we need your help as soon as
president Trump stops speaking we are
going to the Capitol the capital is in
that direction let people know spread
the word tomorrow we need to go into the
capitol into the campus
[Applause]
oh
these movies
huh that's a theory fed fed fed Enrique
tario the leader of the proud boys was
was just arrested and charged and he's
going to face decades in prison for what
he wasn't even in Washington DC that day
he was in a hotel room in Baltimore but
prosecutors charged Enrique tario had
conspired to direct people to go into
the capital riot
well nobody directed people to go in and
riot in the capital more directly than
Ray Epps
and yet he gets a little disorderly
conduct charge slap on the wrist a few
years later so those guys are saying fed
fed fed sounds like a pretty compelling
Theory but
look this is America
and the accused are entitled to due
process so even if other conservatives
jump to conclusions I just want to say
for the record
I believe that special agent apps should
be presumed innocent until proven guilty
I'm Michael Knowles it's the Michael
Mills show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Show YouTube has
demonetized Russell Brand speaking of
being presumed guilty until you're
proven innocent Russell Brand has these
rape allegations against him and so he's
being cut off from all of society in the
economy until maybe he's exonerated
later on maybe he isn't we'll get to
that in a second first though speaking
of federal employees John fetterman has
some really profound
incoherent babblings about leg humping
the house today looks like it's falling
apart you've already got 17 no votes in
that house Republican caucus saying
we're not passing anything what what do
you think is happening here
yeah you know like I I truly I was I was
very proud of my colleagues you know
because they're really about governance
that's what it is and on the other the
house the the whatever they call
themselves Team America or whatever they
call themselves I just like hey I just
like bring your vote you know otherwise
you know they need to go hump a
different leg
um you were in uh you drove your I think
it's a Ford uh from Braddock I love
Chris Hayes doing his best you know he's
a veteran there on MSNBC and so he's
he's heard it all and yet John
fetterman's leg humping comments seemed
to surprise even him and he says uh
um uh-huh yeah well uh anyway moving on
we could we let's talk about anything
else please
it was less offensive when Caligula
tried to send his horse to the Roman
senate then it is that the Democrats are
pretending that John Federman is a
functional senator
and the reason for that is
Caligula trying to send his horse to the
Senate was just a big middle finger to
the entire Roman system of government
especially to the Senate
the Democrats pretending that that John
fetterman is a functioning senator
it's not a transparent middle finger to
us they're trying to deceive us they're
actually trying to pretend that this guy
is capable of doing the job
it's it's not a Brazen act it's not a
big dare it's not an Fu you know a big
prominent one it's a it's a secret Fu
it's it's an assumption
that we're so stupid and Powerless that
we're not going to notice that this
guy's obviously not up to the job he I'm
not sure he was up to the job before he
had his health problems he certainly
isn't up to the job now and he should go
home and recuperate and and try to get
better and in the meantime there should
be a functioning senator from
Pennsylvania but now they'll just keep
keeping on
they'll keep keeping on it with the
Pennsylvania Senator with the president
of the United States who's also not
functioning all that well
they'll just keep rolling along
until
the whole thing collapses now oddly
enough
John Federman is not the least coherent
national leader in our nation's capital
that I think would have to go to
Chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
Mark milley
who
though he's been accused of going woke
he he doesn't even know what that word
means is the US military too woke no not
at all um so
um you know I'm not even sure what that
word truly means but
um I would tell you that the military I
see is a military that's exceptionally
strong it's powerful it's ready in fact
our Readiness rates the way we measure
Readiness is better now I don't I don't
even know what that word means what are
you talking about woke you think we're
woke what on Earth what on Earth would
give you the impression that I mark
milley and woke
first of all
on the issue of critical race Theory et
cetera a lobbyists have to get much
smarter on whatever the theory is
um
but I do think it's important actually
for those of us in uniform to be
open-minded and be widely read in the
United States Military Academy is a
university and it is important that we
train and we understand uh and I I want
to understand white rage
want to understand white rage I want to
understand critical race Theory
I wanna but I don't know what woke is
what are you talking about woke it's
just very important that every single
one of our Cadets reads even Max candy
every day to understand the evil of
their whiteness
I believe for a fit fighting force we
must attend Robin D'Angelo seminars to
uh to become conscious of our
unconscious racial and sexual biases so
that we no longer
exert phobias
on this world
I don't know what woke means
I'll tell you what woke means because
some conservatives have struggled to
explain what woke means to woke is just
the extreme conclusion of liberalism
that's all it is
and liberalism was famously once
described as uh the the liberal being
the man who can't take his own side in
an argument
that's what it is
it's the extreme conclusion
of an ideology predicated on a radical
individualism that culminates in
absurdity that is contrary to human
nature and to reality more broadly
that's what woke is
and as the US Military
adopts policies that contradict Human
Nature
in particular on one sexual matter that
we're not allowed to talk about on big
Tech I think you know the one I'm
talking about
as the U.S military decides to focus its
attention
and things like critical race Theory
rather than on killing our enemies
uh that would invert the purpose of that
institution make it much less ready to
fight and uh have it view the world in a
way that is contradictory to reality
I don't know what that means I'm gonna
have to read a little bit more
Kimberly Crenshaw then I'll understand
then we'll be a real fighting for us now
when you want to go out there and be the
best fighting fit person that you can
possibly be that's gonna involve how you
dress how you present yourself all the
way down to your
undergarments which is why you got to
check out Tommy John right now go to
tommyjohn.com Knowles listen this is a
family show I don't want to get too
intimate with you here but all I'm going
to tell you is this
Tommy John makes the greatest boxer
shorts ever made period
when you get new
undergarments with Tommy John you will
also get 20 off your order with promo
code normal skin wlas their underwear
has dozens of comfort Innovations
breathable lightweight moisture wicking
fabric four times the stretch of
competing brands that can keep you much
cooler than cotton Tommy John also has
loungewear with a level of softness like
never before and is designed to envelop
you in a world of pure luxury every
purchase is backed by Tommy John's best
pair you'll ever wear or its free
guarantee I I'm not joking I didn't
realize Tommy John was coming back on
the show for reads I was thinking about
this just within the last few weeks I
pulled out a pair of Tommy Johns I
thought man these are just the greatest
boxers ever get 20 off your first order
right now tommyjohn.com Knowles
tommyjohn.com Knowles see site for
details go to
tommyjohn.com Knowles
a liberal is one who cannot take his own
side in an argument speaking of picking
sides president Trump has just announced
as some of us predicted
that he will not be attending the second
GOP Presidential primary debate
a number of Republicans said I don't
think Trump's going to be the first
debate but he will be at the second
debate
I said that I thought it was a smart
political move for Donald Trump not to
show up to the first debate therefore I
thought that it would not hurt him
politically once he didn't show up to
the first debate which is why he would
not be forced to show up to the second
debate
some of us were right some of us were
wrong you know I hate to say I told you
so but it's also why if anyone accuses
me of you know Shilling for the Trump
campaign or promoting the Trump campaign
or something like that it's not my
intention and I don't think that's the
effect of what I'm doing I am predicting
what's going on so when I say hey I
think it's really smart for Trump not to
show up to the first debate
if if it turned out that Trump's poll
numbers cratered after not showing to
the first debate you might say well
Michael either your predictions are
wrong your faculties of predicting are
wrong or you're just a hack for the
Trump campaign because you want to say
that whatever he's doing is the right
thing
but if my prediction turns out to be
true as it was a minority prediction in
in among conservatives then I think you
have to maybe conclude that Donald Trump
is actually making smart political
choices here and to state that is not to
promote his campaign it's just to
observe reality and it to observe the
reality of the state of the presidential
race which according even to
RealClearPolitics average of the polls
has not changed really even one iota in
about 15 months now so Trump sees okay I
didn't show up to the first debate
didn't hurt me actually my poll numbers
went up slightly and my number one
opponent's poll numbers went down
slightly okay I'm not going to show up
to the second one but what's he going to
do is he going to have another
conversation with Tucker Carlson on
Twitter no
he's got to mix it up
this time according to the New York
Times
Trump is going to be counter programming
the debate by rallying with striking
Automotive workers
in Detroit
uh this is really really a good idea
because the change that Donald Trump
represents in the GOP
is a turning away from being the party
of Rich Uncle Penny bags it's kind of
funny because he's a billionaire from
New York but what that has represented
reflected in the polls and even the way
that conservative Elite types talk about
it is that he represents a populist turn
in the party so so the GOP is no longer
going to be the party of Paris it's
going to be the party of Pittsburgh it's
no longer going to be the party of Wall
Street it's going to be the party of
Detroit and so Trump is going to
express that by going and rallying with
the Auto Workers here
before I get to the auto worker strike
what does this mean for the the primary
candidates who are debating if this
second debate doesn't move the numbers
for anybody if it doesn't seriously
hamper Donald Trump's support and if it
doesn't improve the support for any of
the other candidates I think these
primary candidates need to to cut it out
they got to drop it because it's not
going to help them at all they're going
to keep putting on this Sideshow until
their campaigns fall apart this is
especially true of Ron DeSantis
if Ron DeSantis wants to seriously
take a shot at Donald Trump and maybe
dislodge him from the top spot I'm not
saying it's impossible now no no primary
votes have been cast yet what he's got
to do is stop playing along with the
same old tired strategy that's going to
leave him as a very solid number two or
number three finisher and allow Donald
Trump to have the nomination what I
would recommend if I were on the
DeSantis campaign right now
let's see forget about the stupid
debates we'll see what happens after the
second but if the poll numbers don't
move I'd say forget about the stupid
debates forget about the stupid regular
old campaigning like it's an ordinary
primary which is obviously not I would
encourage DeSantis to take up the
Abraham Lincoln strategy that Lincoln
did before the Lincoln Douglas debates
do you know how the Lincoln Douglas
debates came along is that you had
Stephen Douglas politician in Illinois
going around making his speeches he
didn't agree to do a bunch of debates
with Abraham Lincoln Abraham Lincoln
just started following him around and
giving speeches after Douglas was
finished
show up to the Douglas events and be a
little thorn in Douglas's side
and give speeches afterward finally
Stephen Douglas agrees to have the
series of debates with him
that's what DeSantis is going to have to
do and I know right now the DeSantis
campaign is trying not to look desperate
and is trying to to just pretend that
everything's going fine and no actually
secretly they're going to win Iowa and
actually then they're going to start
winning all the primary states and no
big deal forget about the polls ignore
reality ignore the committed caucus
goers okay that that is a path toward
loss you have to ignore if you want to
have a shot at it you have to
acknowledge that things are looking very
very bad and you need to start making
bold choices in the primary
so bold I think is to just go around if
Donald Trump's giving a speech with the
Auto Workers then Rhonda Santa should
show up afterward and give a speech
about why Donald Trump's wrong about
everything if that's what DeSantis
really believes
but but this is what's also been the
difficult thing for the DeSantis
campaign DeSantis needs to make a strong
case that he is radically different from
Trump but the lane that DeSantis is
running in is the Trump Lane but some of
the support that DeSantis is attracting
is the anti-trump support so it's it's
put him in a tough position I totally
agree this is a tightrope walk if the
campaign is going to be anything at all
but
playing along to the normal rules of the
game
is not very likely to help
the polls haven't moved and Trump is
over 40 points up
now what about that auto worker strike
the Auto Workers strike is something
that could be a wedge issue for
conservatives because conservatives are
generally not very pro-union
there have been times when conservatives
have been pro-union but really since the
80s and 90s we've we've had this
caricature of being very anti-union
so what do we think do we like the auto
worker strike do we not like it
conservatives will be the first ones to
tell you that the auto unions destroyed
the city of Detroit and then a lot of
automobile manufacturing went overseas
and that was that didn't help the
workers didn't help anybody
but in this case
the what are the Auto Workers striking
over
they're striking over
the Biden Administration
gramming a bunch of climate change BS
down their throats to try to force these
automakers also ESG and also the
investors and also the corporations
forcing these stupid electric vehicles
down their throats that are upending
their way of life
and producing things that a lot of
people don't even want
so how do we feel I feel pretty good
about this strike
I like the strike a lot I don't like it
when I don't know the national teacher
Union goes on strike because they want
to keep the schools shut down 10 more
years after covet I don't like that
strike I don't like that Union
particularly but I do like this strike
and I do like this Union
I think conservatives especially if we
really are going to become the party of
Pittsburgh rather than the party of
Paris
we've got to be a little more
comfortable with worker
concerns and worker actions and I think
we've got to be a little bit more
comfortable with Collective action
in its proper place I'm not saying
workers of the World Unite we all need
to start reading marks and angles but
we've got to get a little more
particular about these things politics
makes for strange bedfellows right now
the Democrat Party is throwing its
middle finger up to to a lot of union
workers
not to the teacher unions they love the
teacher unions but to Auto Workers in
Detroit
is in Michigan Michigan is a state that
we need to win
and if conservatives want to pick up
those votes we've got to be able to
appeal to different groups of people
than we previously have in the past one
of the arguments for a candidate like
Donald Trump
over a candidate I'm not saying over a
candidate in this primary race I'm
saying over a candidate like a Mitt
Romney who doesn't appeal to union
workers Mitt Romney who says the 47 of
Americans are dirty rotten filthy bums
okay I think a candidate like a trump
appeals to voters more than a candidate
like a John McCain
who doesn't really appeal to those same
people
and so if you're going to try to
assemble a coalition and you say okay
I'm going to lose this group of people
you got to make it up somewhere else
and so a candidate like Trump does turn
off a lot of people he's going to turn
off a lot of
you know center-right and moderate kind
of liberal women in blue places I don't
know you know what the Suburban women
they sometimes say or the fancy
establishment men or what okay you're
going to lose those people you got to
pick it up somewhere else where you pick
it up I think Detroit is a Fine Place to
pick up support speaking of collective
action The Blob the Borg is turning
against Russell Brand
who I have learned in recent hours
is not only a British actor who dresses
funny but a podcaster and a figure who's
turned against the establishment
Russell Brand is being deprived of his
livelihood
long before he's ever had any kind of
trial
it's very unnatural we need to restore
balance to nature which is why
you got to check out balance of nature
right now go to balanceofnature.com use
promo code Knowles living a healthy
lifestyle is not easy especially when
you're always on the go you need simple
manageable routines to make sure you're
getting the proper nutrition every day
which is why
I'm a fan of balance of nature balance
of nature fruits and veggies are a great
way to make sure you're getting
essential nutrition every day their
capsules are packed with 100 whole food
that you can take at any time balance of
nature uses a cold vacuum process that
preserves the natural phytonutrients in
whole fruits and vegetables and
encapsulates them for easy consumption
balance of nature sent a bunch of their
products down to the studio for our team
to try we all love them make fruits and
veggies a part of your daily diet your
body will thank you go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code nulls
kwles for 35 off your first order as a
preferred customer that is
balanceofnature.com promo code Knowles
for 35 off your first order my only
recommendation is when you receive it
don't receive it at the daily wire
office where these jackals of producers
and assistants come and steal them all
head on over right now
balanceofnature.com promo code Knowles
have you held out on joining Jeremy's
razors well
now is your chance to enter the woke
free economy with the Precision 5 trial
set one weighted handle one Precision
five razor with flipback trimmer one low
price there has never been a better time
to stop giving your money to woke
corporations that hate you go to
Jeremy's racers.com make the switch
today
Russell Brand
has been suspended from receiving money
on YouTube
amid his rape and sexual assault
allegations these are allegations that
date back many years that hadn't come
out until in the words of these women
journalists called them and why did the
journalists start calling them Russell
Brand was very open I said yesterday on
the show I don't know if he committed
any crimes according to the strict
letter of the law but I have no doubt
that he did extremely depraved
degenerate awful things that certainly
should be illegal
but you don't get to just rewrite the
law exposed facto and they're not going
after him because of whatever he did in
any depraved sexual kind of environment
they're going after him because he
contradicts the prevailing liberal
narrative and the whole reason that the
ruling class encourages all this bizarre
weird sex stuff in Hollywood in the
media and Academy everywhere else the
reason that they do that is so that
they've got compromise on you so if you
ever stop Towing the party line they're
going to say 15 years later oh you're
actually a rapist oh you're at the very
least you're a creep and a weirdo yeah
we're gonna destroy your reputation and
cut off your money and then what happens
the corporations and the platforms that
control our entire Public Square there's
only a handful of them they spring into
action they say yeah you're going to
lose your money you're gonna you're
gonna severely have your ability to
speak restricted and uh then maybe
you'll get a trial maybe you won't but
we're going to ruin your life law before
long before you ever see a day in court
what does this tell us does this tell us
that we should whine and complain and
say YouTube should be neutral
YouTube you guys said you were going to
be neutral and apolitical but you're
actually being political
yes they they are being
YouTube controls Google broadly controls
speech in the Public Square controls 90
of the flow of information around the
internet
yeah they're political political just
means public
obviously they're political
we're convinced some of us are convinced
that YouTube and Google and Facebook and
Bud Light and ancisor Bush Kaiser bush
all of these corporations that they're
not political because they're just in
the economy they're just they're sort of
private they're not the government
they're not that's just the wrong way of
thinking about it
there is no avoiding politics and
obviously economic power has a political
Dimension to it
this is one of the Real Lies of
liberalism is it is it tells you that
politics is just one little tiny segment
of society
and there's politics there's the economy
there's a civil society there's this
there's that there's this there's that
but in practice at The crucial moments
we see that isn't true
at The crucial moments we see oh
actually those economic Powers those
private Powers the the isps the social
media platforms the this that and the
other thing
they're going to work toward political
ends so so the culmination that you you
of of this whole liberal project is that
you just have the Outsourcing of
political power away from the people
toward
a handful of billionaires in Silicon
Valley who are going to do whatever the
hell they want and
you think that you have no ability to
to influence the government often that's
the case but you I promise you you have
far less ability to influence Google or
YouTube or these gazillionaire too big
to fail corporations many of which were
built with help of the state
that don't really care if you say well
I'm going to stop using Google no you're
not
no you're not Google is the
infrastructure of the internet not gonna
stop it at all
well my business is going to stop
advertising on Google no you're not they
own advertising on the internet
they're essentially a state utility
they just are even less accountable than
the government is
the only way out is going to be through
folks
this was the this was the same kind of
argument we've been having for seven
eight years now in public conservatives
are finally waking up used to be well
hands-off look it's a private
Corporation you don't like it build your
own Google well look I don't like what
you say but I'll defend to the death
your right to say it for some reason and
I don't care what we teach students in
schools I don't care what they think
just how they think or what you try to
pretend this neutrality there's no
neutrality in politics guys there's no
you stand in the middle of the road
you're gonna get hit by a truck okay
if you if you try to compromise between
good and evil what what happens what do
we read about in the Bible you will be
disgusting to everybody you will be spit
out for being lukewarm
don't be lukewarm speaking of
corporations in politics
and presidential candidates Senator Tim
Scott
who's just touring around Iowa and he
says he tweeted out he said I got a
little hungry on the road in Iowa good
thing I spotted the golden arches and he
posted a picture of himself holding up
some McDonald's french fries with a
little hamburger
on the tray
and I zoomed in I said look I'm
something of a fast food Aficionado
myself I'm on the road a lot even when
I'm not on the road if sweet little
Elise is out of town I like
I like fast food I zoomed in and I saw
Senator Scott was eating a Big Mac
and I said I don't
I don't believe that this man is a
regular user of McDonald's
I don't believe it
because nobody who is a regular user of
McDonald's would ever choose a Big Mac
today
over a Double Quarter Pounder with
cheese
because you see the the Big Mac back in
the olden days Big Macs used to be a
kind of a nice sandwich
now they're not the patties are very
thin dry
it's all just bread and shredded lettuce
and and Russian dressing
Secret Sauce the Double Quarter Pounder
with cheese
nice thick juicy patties nice fresh beef
it's so much better and why do I say all
of this not only because I'm very
passionate about American fast food
but because
that tweet seems to me inauthentic
it seems inauthentic and people don't
like that anymore and that's how
politicians used to campaign
and say how do you do fellow normal
people or yes I am one of you yes and
I don't know why that changed exactly
maybe authenticity was always sort of
nice uh and but but no I don't think so
even Ronald Reagan one of the great
presidents in American history he didn't
come off as authentic he seemed sincere
I don't think he was a liar or cynical
but Ronald Reagan was an actor and well
so much of his presidency seemed well I
would have to say it a little bit
scripted right and it's good I mean
there was good presidency
but now think about the difference
between that age
and the age of
Trump or the age of Barack Obama for
that matter even Barack Obama seemed a
little more casual a little looser a
little a little bit more
authentic maybe that's because media now
is so much more intimate if you're
listening to the show right now maybe
you're in your car maybe you've got some
earbuds in you're walking around doing
work cleaning the dishes I don't know
where but you're certain it could be in
your home in your on your bed watching
on the computer it's very very intimate
to say nothing of the Advent of reality
TV which is now just transformed into
little reels of random people on the
internet taking handheld videos in their
Apartments it's very intimate it's not
big Hollywood stages with all the
lighting and all of the makeup artists
and all of the scripting it's not that
anymore and I think some of the
candidates are are at a disadvantage
because of it I I don't mean to beat up
on Tim Scott too much he's a wonderful
guy and uh he's doing better as a
presidential candidate than some people
thought he would but
this seems very very old school this
kind of thing seems very dated No One
Believes that Tim Scott actually sent
that tweet
No One Believes that most politicians
send their tweets
Donald Trump was attacked for all of his
tweets but people believed that he was
sending them and that creates a personal
intimate connection
which goes a very long way there are
people from who are working on other
presidential campaigns saying why do you
still like Trump why do you people still
like Trump he did this stupid thing and
he did this bad thing and he said this
dumb thing and all of that's true all of
that can be true but that personal
intimate connection
can go a very long way you see it when
the guy is on the campaign Trail
speaking of Republican lawmakers
Politico is reporting now
that a GOP lawmaker a senior GOP
lawmaker in the house
has said that there are not sufficient
votes among Republicans to continue
funding the war in Ukraine
and there are the Democrats want to keep
funding the war some Republicans want to
keep funding the war but this senior
house Republican person
Anonymous reportedly told Politico quote
we do not have the votes in the
Republican conference to do any Ukraine
funding to which I say
LOL
oh you sweet summer child
you think
do you seriously think that you need
Republican votes in the house to fund
the war in Ukraine do you seriously
think
that you need any votes in the house to
fund the war in Ukraine
you don't
what they're gonna do
is they're just gonna make up the money
they're just gonna find it somewhere
or what they're going to do is they're
going to change the prices of the
materials that we're sending to Ukraine
and say oh actually we have extra money
they already did this they did this back
in June remember the headline back in
June
the the US government misplaced six
billion dollars and and we just found it
and it was actually supposed to go to
Ukraine so we're just giving them six
billion dollars that we had accidentally
misplaced
that headline wasn't exactly true that
but it was it was substantially true but
the real story was that the US
government wanted to keep funding the
war in Ukraine and
they found it politically inconvenient
to go through the whole rigmarole of
getting a new vote and getting people to
commit to funding publicly so what they
did was they changed the prices of the
weapons that we're sending to Ukraine
retroactively so they say oh actually
the weapons that we sent Ukraine they're
actually worth less than we previously
said they were worth so and that means
because we already approved a bazillion
gazillion dollars to Ukraine because
we're retroactively changing the price
of the weapons that means we've got more
money to send them more weapons okay
great there you go here's here's the
equivalent of six billion dollars of
more weapons but it the number is just
completely made up
doesn't doesn't matter they'll just do
this again the US government
will not give up the war in Ukraine
because of some Republican Congressman I
promise you that that is not how our
government works
our government operates largely outside
of the purview of the house certainly of
the U.S Senate and perhaps even of the
U.S president
it just kind of rolls along
which is how you can have Caligula's
horse over there from Pennsylvania as as
the U.S senator and how you can have Joe
Biden who
doctors I don't think have yet properly
concluded whether or not he's actually
alive or dead and just hung up by
Marionette strings but it doesn't really
matter if Joe Biden can pronounce his
own name or figure out which way to walk
around a room the government just keeps
rolling along that is especially true
when it comes to foreign policy and the
funding of a war now speaking of Ukraine
speaking of our great Global challenges
Vladimir zielinski
showed up in his Fidel Castro military
fatigues to the United Nations and he
just gave a speech on the real
threat we face which ultimately
apparently is not even the Russians even
though humanity is failing on its
climate policy objectives this means
that extreme weather will still impact
the normal Global Life and some evil
state will also weaponize its outcomes
and when people in the streets of New
York
and other cities of the world went out
on climate protests we all have seen
them and when people in Morocco and
Libya and other countries die as a
result of natural disasters
and when islands and countries disappear
underwater and when tornadoes and
deserts are spreading into into new
territories and when all of this is
happening one unnatural disaster in
Moscow decided to launch a big war and
kill tens of thousands of people
[Music]
we have to stop it
you see what he's doing here what he's
doing here is what would happen when a
conquered people
would finally accept the rule of the
Conquering Empire the Roman Empire comes
in conquers some far-flung people and
what do the leaders of that people do to
show their obedience to show that
they've been vanquished they begin to
worship the Roman gods
that is what he's doing
that is how Vladimir zielinski is
proving his loyalty as a vassal state
to the West the liberal the liberal West
and trying to get that sweet sweet
funding from the liberal West is he's
he's paying worship to the new gods of
the liberal West and in this case that
would be mother Gaia that would be
climate change that's the the animating
religion
now I I hesitate to say that
environmentalism Global warmingism has
fully replaced Christianity as the
religion of the West I don't think
that's possible because I think
Christianity is true and so there's no
replacement theology for that because
that's the true thing and it's never
going away uh however there are great
many liberal Elites who live their lives
as though that is the case their
theological worldview is shaped much
more by climate change that's the that's
the cause the moral cause that affects
everything the economy a family life the
political order everything
and Vladimir zielinski who just wants to
not be taken out by a cup of polonium
tea from Vladimir Putin Vladimir
zielinsky who wants to keep his country
from becoming part of Russia he comes
and he says okay the only way to do it
is to be
part of the West and have the West fund
this war for me and the way to do that
is to pay homage and worship to their
gods and at what a damning what a
damning display that the gods to which
he has to pay worship are the pagan
Pagan nature gods of climate change
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Summer D 7668 who says how can they be
trusted to uphold defend and enforce the
Constitution if they can't even enforce
a dress code very good point if you are
not able
mentally and physically to make yourself
presentable in the morning
if you can't understand
the intricacies of of putting on a
business suit
and why that might matter in public life
you're probably not going to be able to
uphold the political order of a Nation
because politics is very very
complicated a lot of people on the left
and the right really want to simplify
our system of government so it's all
about rights
no it's all about freedom
no actually it's all about equality and
really what the founding fathers wanted
was and then they insert whatever their
pet project is and now read the
Federalist
read the Anti-Federalist
arguments read
the debates that were going on in the
18th century
our system of government is extremely
complicated and as we have chipped away
at it for so long over the years it's
become a bit more fragile
and if you can't figure out how and why
you should wear a business suit
you might not be in the best position to
defend it
speaking of Ukraine
my friend Jack besobic is apparently on
a Ukraine hit list
You Know Jack
conservative journalists speaker you've
seen him and about he and I have done
events together and been on each other's
shows and anyway Ukraine apparently
wants to Murder Jack
it's not good
how did I find this out well uh because
there's this website
that that
lists enemies of Ukraine and it's
supposedly an unofficial website but it
looks a little bit sort of affiliated
with the country
uh
what what Jack said here is after the
collapse of his counter-offensive
zielinski's biggest threat is not me
it's his own intelligence Services hope
you don't get put on the cia's early
retirement plan Vlad drop the receipts
on the bidens and we'll get you a nice
mcmansion in Sarasota uh so so Jack's on
this list
list includes Tulsi gabbard prime
minister Victor Orban Roger Waters from
Pink Floyd because he's spoken out
against Ukraine I'm pleased to see I'm
not on the list even though I did this
long Thread about the Ukraine military
spokesman who's an American dude who
dresses up like a chick uh I'm at least
as far as I can tell I'm not on this
list uh the the organization that puts
out the list is called mirotovores which
ironically translates to Peacemaker they
say it's separate from the government
but I don't really buy it because it was
founded in 2014 by a former Ukraine
government Minister George Tuka it's
it's reported to be run by a former
member of Ukraine State intelligence
under an alias Roman zaitsev
and according to the times of London the
list has been used by government
officials at checkpoints in Ukraine
in addition to official government
databases
so
when that uh psycho spokesman for the
Ukraine military
the American
when he said
that he didn't really threaten any
journalists
that's a lie first of all it's a lie
because we saw the video
where he said any Russian propagandists
were hunting you down but now we see the
list
and the list includes
not only journalists but American
journalists
not only American journalists but Jack
besobic
sure looks like that was the case and
sure looks like it it uh undercuts the
liberal's argument that the great
Defenders of Journalism no they're not
and the argument that journalism that's
the fourth estate the people who speak
truth to power it's not that either
political forces have
spokesman political forces have people
who articulate and communicate those
views
and the Liberals view their opposing
journalists as enemies here and abroad
and they view their journalists as not
the speakers of Truth to power they view
them as propagandists which is often
what they are
one story I got to get to this is so is
a creepiest story I've seen in a long
time a teenage girl found an iPhone in
an airplane bathroom and it was an
iPhone underneath the seat or behind the
seat to basically catch her naked and
this was after a flight attendant a male
flight attendant on I think it was
American Airlines
told her hey come up to the use the
bathroom in the first class cabin and
then he was in there first then she goes
in uses the bathroom then she sees him
go back in there presumably to take this
iPhone the family is extremely Disturbed
as well they should be my my thought on
this is I mean I hope the family sues I
hope this guy goes the guy ended up
getting arrested apparently once the
plane landed but my main thought on this
uh other than just revulsion and disgust
is
how
many things had to go wrong in this
guy's life how many bad turns did this
guy have to take to get to the point
where he was planting a camera in an
airplane bathroom for a 14 year old girl
to film her in states of undress in kind
of disgusting States among breast too
because you're in a bathroom
how how perverted do you have to be
and then it reminded me
of one of the great Norm Macdonald bits
about Bill Cosby and hypocrisy as my
buddy says the worst part about Cosby
was he was a hypocrite and I said I
don't think that was the worst part
to me the worst part of the raping
way up high
and then the second would be the
drugging
and then the third would be the scheming
thank you but anyways hypocrisy would be
way down the line you know like on the
fourth page or something yes that exact
as usual Norm is right and
the libs will say well the worst crime
is hypocrisy that's the worst crime
that's why the Liberals will jump with
joy and applaud and be so happy about
depraved sexual acts taking place at
Pride parades that's why they'll be so
thrilled and happy about drag queen's
Story Hour inviting
to go talk to five-year-olds they'll be
they'll say it's wonderful it's
expressive it's great but then Lauren
bobert gets caught on a hidden camera in
a in a dark theater doing things that
are that are untoward and they'll try to
throw the book at her because what they
say is no it's not what she did it's the
hypocrisy that's the worst part
which by the way they confuse hypocrisy
with just having standards and failing
to live live up to them which is called
sinning which is called being a human
but yeah hypocrisy hypocrisy is bad
failing to have a standard is bad being
an active hypocrite and pretending to
have a standard and then it
intentionally uh undermining that that's
worse that's true
but like what about the what about the
scheming you know that to me that's the
darkest part of the story like no the
darkest part is that this 14 year old
girl was traumatized in an airplane
bathroom that's the worst part
but the most unsettling part of it
is all the scheming think about how much
this guy sat at home scheming and
thinking and entertaining bizarre
thoughts in his head and you know this
guy is completely addicted to porn and I
bet this guy's looking at pretty creepy
porn if he's doing this to a 14 year old
girl and just the his entire life must
be just filled like a room filled with
with just poison gas with just all of
this hideous stuff
and all of which is to say it's a
reminder
to get off that path early before
because it can get really really bad to
get off that path early this is the
wisdom the traditional Christian wisdom
of avoiding the near occasion of sin
this one moment you're entertaining
weird thoughts the next Mo you know
maybe you're looking at bad stuff
whatever and then the next moment you
find yourself as an airplane Steward
doing really creepy stuff
at thirty thousand feet the rest of the
show continues now you do not want to
miss it become a member use code
knowleskin wlas check out for two months
free on all annual plans
foreign
[Music]